okay you and you debts use these I don't
know I apologize for the disheveled look
oof oh gosh that's really but I just I
just had to do a homework out because
the gym is closed to do two stars and I
want you if you can take the time to
watch this whole video because I do need
to explain some context here
first off two cute Maddy is sick she
doesn't have coronavirus and I apologize
if it my shoulder is tired and sore so
this might be bouncing around a lot
she doesn't have stars or coronavirus
but she does have a pretty bad flu so
she won't be in for a while if you could
send her your what wishes that'd be
great I do have an announcement to make
here before you before you close this
video hear me out
and send me have a send me some comments
how the corona virus has affected you or
what you're doing what precautions are
taking what level of a threat you as I
almost say threat what level of a threat
apparently from from the North st. Louis
what level of a threat you think this is
so I've noticed a few things I've
noticed at all the other late night
hosts out there Stephen Colbert Jimmy
Kimmel Trevor Noah you know they're all
broadcasting from their their bathtub or
their backyard and these are main
networks like CBS and and even Comedy
Central and apparently no one thought to
get Stephen Colbert a shotgun microphone
as he broadcast from his barbecue I
guess it adds the whole kind of cabin
fever vibe which is you know an easy
sell these days and a lot of people had
to step step step back right scale
everything back we see that and this is
a conversation that we had to have with
our team about what was an acceptable
risk
what are unacceptable risks during this
time obviously taking every precaution
that we can and looking out for the
employees I want to be Chris thank you
so much to everyone who has already
joined my club no one has been let go
there have been no pay cuts everyone is
being taken care of to the to the best
of our abilities which at this point is
continued without a hitch but in seeing
everyone else step down you know I've
realized that um kind of one of our
benefits here is we don't have a hundred
forty seven employees like Trevor Noah
terminal has 20 something writers we
don't have a hundred and fifty employees
like Stephen Colbert we have I believe
ten in the office and then five who kind
of work remotely and now eight in the
office and
so while everyone else is stepping back
while they're scaling down
I wanted to officially announce that mug
club is going to be stepping up so you
may notice that we didn't release any
video yesterday any show yesterday today
was supposed to be a long form of Tulsi
Gabbard who's bumped or canceled I think
four times now so I doubt that's ever
going to happen but um we are actually
going to make mug Club available and
free a lot of people on YouTube don't
realize this anion let me explain this
why - I understand the people out there
who are quarantined right so the risk
here is is is people feel isolated
people are getting cabin fever people
are longing for a sense of community
people have talked about for that third
place you know and um and I'm not a
doctor
we're not emergency response
professionals so we can't do that if
you're if you're having difficulty
breathing don't call me I would I would
call a hospital but what we can do is is
give back in the only way that we know
how and we've been so blessed to have so
many people who joined up at mug Club
and supported us that we are going to
make everything available for people on
you to who have yet to join for free in
front of the paywall so not all four
shows a week are going to be available
for the entire month we're going to
start next Monday so we'll make the
official announcement announcements this
Thursday
tune into the show we'll also be
releasing a tentative schedule and not
only are we releasing everything it's
behind mug club for one month but we're
also adding more content than ever we're
going to do a three time three times per
week morning show
good morning mug club that's going to be
live streamed on YouTube in the morning
Monday Wednesday Friday we are going to
be doing more long-form interviews we're
going to be doing some live video game
streaming we are going to be in the
studio doing everything we can to serve
you and that's going to come with a
steep discount because we know that a
lot of people are hurting right now and
joining mug club is difficult and I
think we're gonna have several discounts
as well as some giveaways if I get any
five said this on Twitter if I get any
federal relief check it is going to be
given away to someone who is a member of
my club period and you can take that to
the bank or PayPal whatever you choose I
guess PayPal's connect it to your bank
will be giving away I think some some
coffee
potentially some some wall third year
maybe firearms and for people by the way
who are already a members of Mudd Club I
know so and we're really fortunate
people who are members of Mudd Club um
are not selfish and I know you guys are
you don't feel like you're screwed if
this goes out for free for your fellow
Americans for one month but you are
going to get more - for people who have
already paid for my club for example the
the live chats we aren't going to be
doing live chats but we're not going to
be using YouTube's live chats or the
YouTube membership some people say why
don't you YouTube live chats because
we're demonetised and I don't want to
give them an extra red cent but we will
be doing live chats from people at Mudd
Club on theblaze we have we have a
software technology app I don't know I
had a tech person I just hit the button
on the camera after doing kettlebell
swings we doing live chats will be doing
giveaways it'll be more conversational
so you'll be watching between 7 to 9
shows a week of just a lot of Escada
just to our team here from March 30th
evan goes next Mondays when it starts
will be releasing all the details on
Thursday all the way through April 30 so
the whole month of April will be free in
front of the pay wall with some
discounts because this is how we can
give back we want to and this is a
partially selfish listen I want to
interact with you guys I want to have
more conversations with you guys there's
so much to talk about that sometimes
it's tough to fit into you know one show
a day or sometimes we do it we do a meet
segment that you know is painstakingly
research where we have to provide
sources and it overlays and we have to
write jokes and tape all these sketches
and that's great there's a lot of
production value and and we're only able
to do it through mud club by the way
people people who are members of Mudd
Club I know sometimes you see like well
change my mind is in from the paper the
only free content only exists because of
the paid content if people don't join my
club this doesn't exist and we wouldn't
be able to do this for you so we will be
in studio the whole team matting I was
standing to humanity until she gets
better we will be broadcasting for you
day in and day out more live streams
more experimental content more giveaways
more interaction frankly because it's
it's it's the only thing that I know how
to do I was trying to think about how we
can help back and like we did with
Hurricane Harvey we raised six figures
for hurricane Harvey and we felt you
know what's out really good about that
um we were
happy that we were able to use our
subscription here our team our chain
gang if you will for good and I was
trying to think of how to how to do that
here and I realize you know it's not
rocket science
listen you guys have been generous
enough to bless me with your time every
week or every day for my club members
and we are in a position unlike all of
the other late-night shows and frankly a
lot of the online shows it surprises me
if this would be forgivable for anyone
right to just start broadcasting from
their bathtub it would be a show like
this right there show this started from
the ground up online as a podcast but we
don't it seems backwards to me that you
guys are home that you guys are
quarantined you want more content than
ever or you were quite you need it more
than ever to feel a sense of community
and people are scaling back and giving
you crappier quality and also the way we
can give back is just like with the Vox
ad pocalypse we went against the grain
and we were able to do that because of
you right now we can swim against the
current when everyone else is scaling
down we are going to be stepping up for
as long as time allows well as long as
time allows through through April until
unless someone gets coronavirus you know
what is Argos Corrado's we do have a
couple of masks just a couple we've had
them as props for a long time well
actually you know we shouldn't use them
I think I think we've used them already
so they're no longer good unless we
could spray them down with the right
liquid so um the discount is going to be
pretty significant I think we're gonna
have an extra discount for people who
sign up long term it's going to be
announced on Thursday all the details a
schedule so Monday through Thursday
shows and then Monday Wednesday Friday
every morning a morning Drivetime show
as well going for news of the day in
fact checking liberal sources every
morning so we'll be watching CNN
Huffington Post New York Times and and
and cutting through news of the day
without a ton of pre-production but the
ability to bring up overlays in fact
check in real time so I don't know what
all of the content is going to look like
I know Thursday's going to be the same
we're not going to be able to do super
videos we had a huge change my mind
schedule to try to confront schedule we
actually had one that I don't want to
talk about because if the event gets
uncannily that could be pretty
significant but it involved actually a
published peer-reviewed paper that was
accepted on an absurd topic so since we
can't do super videos we can do
more content and I really do look
forward to talking with you guys
interacting with you guys and frankly
not not only you but spending more time
in the studio with with my best friends
who are there physically in the studio
and some of my best friends who watch
the show thank you so much really
appreciate it we'll have the hash tag
all the details sorry I'm being
repetitive I'm being repetitive because
something about the phone makes you
speak redundant Li ah I hate myself
everyone else is scaling back we're
stepping up free mug Club month and more
content than ever
tune in Thursday